how should a writer start a screenplay I
think if you want to write a screenplay
you should take the path of least
resistance so start the screenplay
however feels easiest and most fun to
you right if you don't know where to
start I think a good place to start is
with just a brain dump so I think
sitting down with whether it's you know
notebook and pen or on your laptop or
whatever and just writing down
everything you know about the story and
it doesn't even have to be stuff that
you know that happens in the story it
can be things that you like about this
type of movie so I love horror movies
because they scare the pants off of me
and they make me grab my boyfriend's arm
or whatever it is you can write all of
that stuff down that's all part of like
what you're going to try to get into
your project right so everything that
inspires you about it maybe why you want
to write it maybe the last movie you saw
that felt sort of like you would like
your movie to feel movies that inspire
you and then also in that same document
I would also try to put everything that
you do know about the story so the idea
that I have is about this guy and this
is his backstory and these are his
friends and this is the situation he
finds himself in and I don't know where
this goes but he encounters some sort of
swamp monster and you know stream of
conscious the consciousness just brain
dump I think that's the great place to
start your story for two reasons one
because it gets you to kind of like
download your spark of inspiration right
which is really useful later on when
you're feeling bored and tired of your
story you can revisit that document and
remember like what was it like when I
fell in love with this story and then
the second reason is that you can
actually pull a lot of the sort of
elements that you need to start building
your story from that document so if you
said I know it's about this guy who you
know grew up in Texas that's probably
your protagonist right so that gives you
one of your elements and you can sort of
start circling the things that you've
written down that you may not have known
were important yet but you can start
using those elements to build your story
from so that's where I that's where I
think everyone should start if they
don't know where to start start with a
brain dump and is that a natural part of
being close to a screenplay for a long
time as you will get bored and tired of
it
that doesn't mean need to abandon it
yeah I think I I can't remember if I've
ever met a writer who didn't say at some
point or another they got tired of the
project they were working on but you
know one of the most common things that
I hear people say is I can't look at the
script anymore so I need a fresh set of
eyes on it right so I think it's totally
natural totally common to be you know
because the writing process is so much
longer than you think it's going to be
usually for the most part every script
that you work on is going to take more
drafts than you expect and you know they
may not be full rewrites or full drafts
but there's always one more thing that
oh if I connected these elements that
would you know give it more meaning or
if I went through and tweaked the
dialogue of this person that would give
them more you know more characterization
or whatever so there's always more to do
so the writing process is always longer
than you think it's going to be so I
think that yes that's very common to
fall out of love with your project at
some point or another probably multiple
times and that's why it's really useful
to kind of crystallize your spark of
inspiration at the very beginning so
that you can revisit it later
you know when you are feeling low about
it and feeling like oh why did I ever
start this you know you can go back to
that initial like true love feeling
you